ce petit atelier installé dans le centre
ville de montigny le bretonneux a ouvert
lé 2 juin dernier une ouverture suite à
la mise en place par le gouvernement de
la prime coup de pouce vélo dans le
cadre du déconfinement led pouvant aller
jusqu'à 50 euros permet une remise en
état complète du deux roues
aucune démarche pour le client c'est
l'état qui rémunère directement
l'entreprise s'est beaucoup de la remise
en état pour des personnes qui
souhaitent qui souhaite aller au boulot
en vélo qui souhaitent utiliser vélo
beaucoup plus souvent
donc c'est souvent des vélos qui
ressortent de la cave depuis des années
qu'on a qu'on a laissée dans un coin
parce que parce qu'on n'a aucun intérêt
à réparer un vélo parce qu'on ne veut
pas et donc la prime a permis justement
à des personnes qui ne faisaient pas de
vélo mais qui en avait un qui en
posséder un de le réparer et donc et
donc j'espère d'enfer d'enfer après pour
aller à droite à gauche quoi vélo'v
propose un forfait à 55 euros qui
comprend l'entretien pour un changement
de pneus ou de pièces et en supplément
pas besoin de rendez-vous les usagers
viennent directement à l'atelier déposer
leurs vélos en moyenne 24 heures
suffisent pour un check-up plus on va
vite plus on va chercher sur le grand
plateau ici et sur l'opinion derrière je
n'arrivais plus à passer certaines
vitesses voilà donc donc c'était
l'occasion n'ai eu à débourser que cinq
ans pour ceux qui ont du mal oui c'est
très bien pour un pour inciter à faire à
remettre en état le vélo ou à faire plus
de vélo mais en dix jours une
soixantaine de clients ont emmené leurs
deux roues dans cet atelier pour se
refaire une santé
le dispositif gouvernemental est valable
jusqu'à fin 2020